[Musique]
Il y a trois ans, tout le monde au toucher
s'est réveillé
avec un pouvoir
attaché réécrivant les règles de la
réalité je les veux sous contrôle
[Applaudissements]
même si cela nécessite une effusion de sang
je vais vous couper le visage en désordre
oui, ils ont des difformités et des afflictions étranges,
ils sont malheureux,
quoi qu'ils soient,
je pense
qu'ils sont une mine d'or,
vous savez à quoi pourrait ressembler un monde meilleur,
c'est que la mission que vous meniez
oui
j'ai une mission et je '  Je ne suis pas fait
pour ça
mais c'est important
il y a une harmonie dans notre monde qui
vaut la peine d'être préservée le toucher n'est pas une
menace pourtant vous semblez déterminé à
prouver qu'ils sont l'église les puristes
ils sont un danger pour nous
nous avons des ennemis  Je ne sais pas encore
oups
je suis ici pour une raison
notre première réponse ne peut pas être la haine nous
serons alignés dans les rues
je veux que les méchants soient punis et les bons
protégés
vous vous livrez souvent à la violence publique
je sais où je suis dans un combat parce que  je
vois des aperçus de la  futur
quelque chose s'est passé
ce n'est pas amusant de vous regarder vous jeter
un dng comme vous pensez que ça va proposer
pourrait être amusant
[Applaudissements]
il y a un chaos sauvage
attaché à la protection et j'ai besoin d'
informations sur pourquoi nous sommes ici et
ce que nous sommes censés faire ensuite
nous prenons un risque terrible
l'avenir du monde dépend de ce que
je fais l'avenir du monde
dépend du présent
attaché une partie de quelque chose de beaucoup plus grand
[Musique]
toi